concept of proportion is very simple all
we need to do is understand a couple of
simple
examples assume you have a computer
screen of the size 40 cm by 30 cm at
home and you've been asked to draw that
screen in your
notebook what do you do then you cannot
draw a 40 cm by 30 cm screen in your
notebook your notebook would be too
small for that so what you do is scale
the size down this term is very
important you scale the size down it
means you draw a smaller figure which is
similar to the earlier one you may draw
a small screen like this with length 4
cm and width 3 cm this will fit into
your notebook here the ratio of the
length to the breadth is 4 is to 3
if you had a bigger book you would have
maybe scaled it down to 8 cm by 6
cm in this case the ratio of the length
to the breadth would be 8
is6 let's talk about the first case why
4 is to 3 the ratio of the length to the
breadth of the actual computer screen is
40 by 30 when reduced it can be written
as 4X 3 basically if we divide both the
numerator and the denominator by 10 we
get
4x3 now let's look at the second case of
8X 6 the ratio of the actual screen was
40 by 30 if both the numerator and the
denominator are divided by 5 we get an
equivalent ratio of 8X 6 40 / 5 = 8 and
30 / 5 = 6
what did you notice in this example what
are we trying to
maintain we are trying to maintain the
same
ratio all the three ratios 40 by 30
4x3 and 8x 6 are actually equal we just
changed the numerator and the
denominator based on the
requirement here we had to draw a
smaller screen and hence we reduce the
numerator and the denominator
proportionally
that's proportion it's nothing but
equivalent
ratios let's take a similar example to
understand
proportionality look at this person to
sketch this person in your notebook you
would draw a proportional figure like
this all the elements his height his
width his hands his legs have been
proportionally
reduced what if we would have drawn the
figure like this it can clearly be seen
that this sketch is not proportional to
the original person since it's not in
proportion the sketch seems to be a
fatter person even though the person is
lean and Tall this is all you had to
understand in the topic of
proportion now let's get back to our
first example since 40x 30 and 4x3 are
equal ratios we say that 40 by 30 and
4x3 are in proportion
and similarly 40 by 30 and 8x 6 are also
in
proportion if you observed well you'd
say even these two ratios are equal if
we divide the numerator and the
denominator of this ratio by two we get
4x3 hence we say that the ratio is 4 by3
and 8x 6 are also in proportion there's
a special way to to write it we write it
as 4 colon 3 2 colons and 8 colon 6 4
colon 3 simply is the ratio
4x3 and 8 colon 6 is the ratio
8x6 and these two colons in between are
used to denote equal ratios it tells us
that this ratio is equal to this ratio
remember proportion simp simply means
equivalent
ratios and this symbol means the same as
or equal to so this can be read as 4 is
to3 is the same as 8 is to
[Music]